this is a production of Cornell
University
are you here thank you very much for the
introduction and for the invitation to
be here today I've been working with
people from Cornell for a number of
years and it's really nice to actually
be here in person
um for the first time in Ithaca as well
as actually being anywhere in person
nowadays
um and so it's my pleasure to be here
and um and so what I'm going to talk
about today is some work that I've been
doing over the last maybe 10 to 12 years
I'm in my research group but before I do
that I just kind of wanted to um oops
I apologize for the the sound there
doesn't mean to be sound but um I just
want to talk a little bit about some of
the new things my lab is doing that's
really exciting and so one of them is we
just finished building this High
throughput um phenotyping Greenhouse um
at the University of Illinois campus
um where we're really starting to
develop some new techniques and some new
um opportunities to advance
um scientific questions that I'll be
talking about today and I'm only
bringing these up because I'm meeting
with a lot of people and I love to talk
about this stuff and so I just wanted to
kind of just give a little bit of an
overview in addition to this my lab has
just built the largest spider cam system
in the world
um this is a cable based High through
phenotyping system that gives us the
opportunity to measure four hectares of
plants within about two hours generating
about 20 to 30 terabytes of data on an
agnostic platform where we can put
anything on there right now we're doing
High spec um sorry hyperspectral
measurements and and high resolution
lidar
um and uh I run a network of Eddie
covariance towers around the state of
Illinois as well as down in Florida I
don't know if any of you have ever been
to Archbold biological research station
I know Cornell has had strong ties with
um that facility The Buck Island Ranch
for a number of decades now and so I
started doing work down there in about
19 or sorry 2008
um looking at ecosystem scale fluxes and
more recently my lab's starting to get
into the ecophysiology of integrating
land uses with polyculture both in terms
of just standard typical polyculture as
well as in agribulletic systems and so
throughout the next day and a half when
I'm meeting with people if you have any
questions or want to talk about any of
this I'd love to do it
um but what I'm going to talk about
today in more depth is going to be work
that I've been doing
um for gosh it's about 20 years now but
the focus of today is going to be about
the last
10 or 12 years I'm looking at uh prop
responses to climate change and it's not
just the responses that I'm interested
in but it's also opportunities for
adaptation and I'll get into that um
throughout this seminar
um the soy face research facility is
located just south of campus at the
University of Illinois
this is an aerial view where you can see
um if you kind of break my neck looking
up there but you might be able to make
out these different plots each of these
plots
um represent either a control or an
elevated or sorry a control or a global
change
um manipulative plot and uh you know
what I mean by that is that each plot
for these plots will have elevated CO2
nested within those CO2 plots we're
going to have high temperature
treatments maybe some drought awnings to
simulate
um
um
drought
um and and so it's been a great research
facility that's been in existence for
about 20 years
um but it's been something that's been
adapting over time and the impetus for
This research has to do with the primary
fact that CO2 concentrations in the
atmosphere are rising and this is of
course I'm no surprise to anybody in
this room but in addition to Rising CO2
concentrations we're seeing significant
increases in other greenhouse gases such
as nitrous oxide which are in much lower
concentrations but have a much higher
greenhouse gas potential methane
concentrations I remember when I um did
my PhD there was a lot of talk about
methane stabilizing but it hasn't
unfortunately it's it's going up and
then we also have a lot of other really
potent greenhouse gas um you know
chlorofluorocarbons and other types of
refrigerants or
industrial chemicals that have a
substantial impact on on the forcing and
what these greenhouse gases together are
doing are driving global temperatures
higher and so this is just looking at
Northern hemispheric temperatures over
the last thousand or so years that have
been reconstructed or are based on on
measurements in in the recent decades
and there's no doubt that the globe is
warming
and
the fact that CO2 is going up right CO2
is really important for plant physiology
CO2 is the primary
molecule that's used in photosynthesis
and it's how plants grow right so Rising
CO2 is of course important and if you
look at this this graph of
photosynthesis as a function of
temperature and you see this black line
just shifting up to this dashed Line
This represents the impact that Rising
CO2 is likely to have on plant
photosynthetic rates particularly C3
plants all right
temperature of course all metabolic
pathways on a plant are going to respond
to temperature
as a result right temperature is
extremely important Rising temperatures
are really important for the physiology
of plants um and photosynthesis is no
exception and so of course if you look
at Rising temperatures from you know
well current at the time this is 1991.
current CO2 concentrations it's
predicted that temperatures as we get
higher and higher are going to drive
photosynthetic rates lower
but in this 1991 paper published by
Steve long he discussed the synergistic
effects of rising CO2 and Rising
temperature leading to a much greater
stimulation in photosynthesis than if
you either had CO2 alone
or Rising temperatures alone
of course there are other lines on here
which represent physiological
adjustments that a leaf or a plant can
make in response to these new growth
environments and so an elevated CO2 for
example if you get a down regulation of
the primary carboxylating enzyme or
visco you might end up with a
temperature response curve that will
mimic something like this dotted line or
this dotted line
hmm and so there are two parameters that
are particularly important in
understanding how a plant responds to
growth conditions in elevated CO2 or an
elevated temperature and those are best
represented on on this graph here this
is photosynthesis as a function of CO2
concentration inside the leaf and there
are two different functions that are
plotted here this this purple dashed
line represents your rubp regenerated
photosynthesis and and then this blue
line up here represents your rubisco
limited photosynthesis and and the solid
dark black line is what would actually
be represented in a leaf photosynthesis
model as your actual photosynthetic
rates and so there are two parameters
that can really dictate what's happening
with either your visco limited or our
ubp regeneration limited photosynthesis
and that's BC Max for this line and it's
going to be jmax for for this line right
here and I talk about VC Max and jmax
because while this is a temperature
versus CO2 response curve and it's
typically an ACI curve it's typically
what we use to describe BC Max and J Max
this is a same plot but this is
temperature on the x-axis and so you can
imagine that changing VC Max or J Max is
going to change the way that that
temperature response plot is going to
behave right and so the general
shape is going to be the same but where
that inflection between the two limiting
processes or how high or how lower where
the optimum is going to lie could very
well shift based on how the plant
adjusts to these Global change
conditions
and so one of the things that my lab has
been interested in was trying to
understand whether or not these
theoretical predictions that Steve came
up with in 1991 actually come to
fruition if you grow plants under the
real world conditions
and so as I mentioned soy face is a
great place to do this type of
experiment and so this is one of the
pots that I mentioned earlier this is
the aerial view this is about 20 meters
in diameter and these blue pipes will
emit pure carbon dioxide into the air
that the turbulent nature of wind as
it's flowing across the canopy will mix
and carry and distribute throughout the
canopy surprisingly uniformly I mean
there's gradients but it's it's does a
pretty good job I was impressed back
years ago and I'm still impressed when I
think about how this works and so what
my lab wanted to do
well let's look at the CO2 by
temperature interaction and so I took a
design
um that a scaled down design that Bruce
Kimball from USDA in Phoenix Arizona
um uh came up with and I super sized it
and so I I I I I increased the number of
heaters by fourfold
um giving us the opportunity
to get really warm temperatures using
these infrared heating arrays to
simulate higher canopy temperatures in
the context of these control and
elevated CO2 plots and so this would be
one of the heating treatments you can
see here on the right is a view of what
it looks like
and then right above this would be the
reference plot and so what I do is we
measure the temperature of this
reference plot up here and then we
calculate exactly how much output needs
to go to these heaters to maintain some
Target set point
in this case we were shooting for three
and a half degree temperature increase
but it turns out based on variation and
downtime we average to about three to
three degree temperature increase
throughout the season
and so this is what some of the data
looks like this is canopy temperature as
a function of time of day and what we
have here are two different lines that
are hard to distinguish there's a blue a
bunch of blue dots and a bunch of black
dots and they're pretty much on top of
each other
the black dots are your control CO2
non-heated plots
the blue our elevated CO2 plots without
Heating and then we have our two heated
plots the red which you can barely make
out is just Heating and the green is
your heating with elevated CO2
and so this is just example from one
year 2009 I mean it's showing you that
the difference between the black and the
red line is about three degrees Celsius
and the difference between the blue and
the green line is also about three
degrees Celsius
and so one of the things we wanted to
understand okay well yeah we're
increasing the temperature of these but
we're increasing the temperature
relative to what's happening in the
reference plot what's happening in the
reference plot is going to change from
year to year based on just natural
variation from growing season to growing
season and so what I'm showing here is
just the real simplification of what's
going on with precipitation in the gray
bars and what's going on with your
minimum maximum and daily average
temperature for this is just five years
of data I'm showing right now the first
phase of this experiment I mean I'm
showing these relative to your long-term
means and so you can see that three of
the years we were wetter
um and um and actually these are growing
season precipitation and growing season
temperatures not yearly
um and then you can see that there
doesn't seem to be a lot of variation
with temperature but in fact 2009 and
2014 were relatively cool years we see
that that maximum temperatures are
really where you're driving things much
much higher the the higher end of those
um
error bars and so we saw quite a bit of
variation
and so the first phase of the experiment
we really just wanted to know are these
plants responding as Steve Wong in 1991
predicted and and so this is daily
integrated photosynthesis measured with
gas exchange just a bunch of people
taking my core 6400s out there in the
field clamping on the leaves
and measuring photosynthesis as much as
we possibly can from sunrise to sunset
and what we saw was that as predicted
from long 1991 in this first year we saw
a slight decrease in photosynthesis in
elevated temperature and and a slight
increase in elevated CO2 and not
statistically significant but maybe a
little nudge higher in the elevated
temperature plus elevated CO2 and this
is consistent with kind of the
predictions that long 1991 predicted but
then in 2011 which was
a much drier and a much warmer year we
actually saw that uh the long 1991
predictions did not hold up and the fact
that we saw substantial decreases in
photosynthesis and high temperature we
saw increases in photosynthesis in high
CO2 but we did not see this synergistic
effect in fact this elevated temperature
plus CO2 had lower photosynthetic rates
than than the elevated CO2 by itself
and in fact we did this over five years
these are two different papers we saw
the same response occur with regard to C
yield although there wasn't an increase
in seed yield in 2009 in elevated CO2 it
kind of follows the same pattern we saw
with photosynthesis this pattern
actually had a decline in yield for this
combined treatment is even greater
um relative to the CO2 plot than the
decline in photosynthesis and if you
just look at these white bars down here
these are three additional years of data
showing you that most years are actually
kind of following what we're seeing with
2011. and so in fact most years we're
seeing the CO2 plus temperature effect
not doing really well in fact marginally
you know no different than the elevated
temperature alone all right
and so this suggests that the
synergistic effect availability CO2 and
elevated temperature
um actually doesn't
um doesn't hold
and so we're wondering why two things
we're wondering why this says why isn't
this theoretical I mean mechanistically
using the parquar model
the modeling that was done in 1991 you
know that's what we understand of the
mechanism but we're not seeing that with
photosynthesis and we're also seeing
larger declines in yield than we are
seeing declines in photosynthesis in the
high CO2 plus high temperature treatment
and so
um it turns out this was the graph I
showed earlier the control graph like
our ability to control the temperature
um you can see there's not a big
difference between the canopy
temperature for the control and elevated
CO2 without or with heating
most years we actually see something
that looks like this where in the middle
of the day there's a clear difference
your control plots
low CO2 no heating is the lowest
temperature elevated CO2 plots we didn't
add heating to these spots the blue this
is just the fact that elevated CO2
reduces the model conductance that
reduced the model conductance warms the
plant canopy
the red this is three degrees
temperature increase above the black and
then the green is a three degree
temperature increase above above above
the blue
and so what we suspect is happening
um is one of the things is that the
higher temperature in the elevated suit
through plus elevated heating basically
that elevated CO2
induce the model closure is probably
bringing more temperature stress to the
plant canopies than the heating
treatment alone and so we're actually
doing two heating treatments the first
heating treatment is the infrared
heating array the second heating
treatment is the closing model aperture
because of elevated CO2
and in fact if you look at all the other
years I guess I didn't put the graph up
there we see something that looks very
similar to this all right and so we
actually have two separate heating
treatments that are being imposed one
through the infrared heaters one through
just the increase in CO2
but that's not the only story
I mentioned photosynthetic acclimation
when you grow a plant under certain
environmental conditions you end up with
a value for VC Max and a value for jmax
when you change the growth conditions
the growing conditions BC Max and jmx
are likely to change and this is one of
the big challenging aspects of modeling
whether it be at the leaf the canopy or
the ecosystem or the global scale is is
trying to understand how these
physiological parameters which are
really important to driving the carbon
dynamics of an ecosystem it's
understanding how these parameters
change and so from many years of
research I have more than this but we're
seeing a very consistent response in
that with VC Max which again is that
initial portion of the photosynthetic
CO2 response curve we don't see a a
whole lot of difference in the VC Max
for plants grown in control versus
elevated temperature so the Black versus
the red bars
in elevated CO2 we do see significant
declines in VC Max whether or not eating
is given so this heating treatment
doesn't have a big impact on VC Max
independent of what your CO2 treatment
but CO2 treatment does lower VC Max
jmax we generally see a different story
which is that heating tends to decrease
jmax whereas elevated CO2 has a
marginally small impact on jmax although
it's still significant but it's still
there
and so the fact that we're seeing these
adjustments in BC Max and jmax are
actually driving slight shifts in the
photosynthetic temperature response
curve as shown here again elevated
temperature drives photosynthesis lower
um the the dots represent your
temperature Optimum photosynthesis
elevated CO2 increases the temperature
Optimum
um and it it moves the optimum I'm sorry
increases your absolute rate of
photosynthesis and it moves your
temperature Optimum to a higher
temperature
elevated temperature plus elevated CO2
we're seeing a decline in your
photosynthetic rate and maybe a slight
increase in your thermal Optimum all
right and so these processes this this
physiological adjustment is likely
um one of the main drivers at least at
the leaf level
for our Observer responses of
photosynthesis
so one of the things that I was
interested then is trying to figure out
what does this mean for canopy level
photosynthetic rates
and so to do this I relied on a
collaboration I had with um Darren Drury
who was working for JP who was working
for um Praveen Kumar at the University
of Illinois in the department of civil
engineering and then he went on to JPL
and I think he's at Michigan State now
he developed this ml can model which is
a really nice model to look at
um canopy level
um um carbon and energy Dynamics this is
not an ecosystem model at the time it
was just a canopy model
um and he developed it for corn and
soybean
and it incorporates all the mechanistic
understanding that we have of various
different modules that lead to
photosynthetic carbon uptake and energy
balance of what's happening it breaks
the canopy up into 15 different layers
in a Summit annotated fractions I mean
it does a really good job and it's been
validated against any covariance data
that my lab has been collecting at the
University of Illinois
um in in both corn and soybean and so we
figured it's been parametrized and
validated Based on data from IAT
covariant sites let's apply this to um
the the temperature work that we've been
doing and so we took
the VC Max and the jmax values and all
the the physiological measurements we
needed in order to parametrize this
model for each treatment independently
and this is just showing you A visual
representation for 2009 this is soil
level all the way to the top of the
canopy and this is from Midnight to
midnight and the colors represent
photosynthesis and so keep in mind that
these don't seem like they're very high
photosynthetic rates and they aren't but
you have to integrate all 15 layers at
any given point in time to get what the
canopy photosynthetic rate will be and
so we did this for 2009 and 2011. and
then we did the exact same thing but for
the measured parameters for your
elevated CO2 elevated temperature and
your combined elevated CO2 plus elevated
temperature for both ears and you can
kind of see that maybe the intensity of
the colors are shifting
um based on each of these treatments but
here are just the difference plots
between the
um uh treatment minus the control and so
what we're seeing is that the biggest
differences we're seeing in your canopy
photo synthetic rate are that we're
seeing higher photosynthetic rates in
the high CO2
treatments we're seeing decreases in
your photosynthetic rate throughout the
canopy in the high temperature treatment
and in fact it appears and it's
generally so that this represents sort
of an additive effect of this minus this
and so and we see that again for both
years although the differences in the
heating treatment here the the decline
is greater as we the model predicted as
matched with the measurements that we
had from the field
and so then we wanted to ask the
question all right we have this
physiological adjustment that's
occurring DC Max and jmax are changing
does that really matter we just ran the
smile given the variation throughout the
growing season if we just ignore that
acclimation responses of EC Max and jmax
um can we just run the model and and
still get reasonable results and so this
is actually doing the exact same thing
we're changing the model forcing and so
the the temperature and the CO2 data is
there but we've just held all the
physiological parameters constantly and
what we see here again is the difference
plot in this case it's what we got with
or without acclimation and so here you
can see that if we ignore acclimation in
elevated CO2 we're slightly
overestimating your photosynthetic rate
if you ignore acclimation in elevated
temperature I'm sorry I have this the
other way around but if you if you um if
you ignore acclimation in elevated
temperature you're grossly
overestimating
your photosynthetic carbon uptake at the
canopy level and we saw this consistent
for both years and this is just a way to
really summarize that and so this is
your Leaf level daily integrated
photosynthesis and canopy level daily
integrated photosynthesis this top row
is our our control and then we have our
elevated CO2 with and without
acclimation not a big difference here or
here
's our elevated temperature width and
without acclimation now we're starting
to see a pretty big difference right so
you're you're basically over
um uh estimating your photosynthetic
carbon uptake if you're not adjusting
for the physiological responses of
photosynthesis and when you look at the
temperature and CO2 combined treatments
it's the same story you're
overestimating things if you ignore
the acclimation responses and so not
only is this acclimation happening not
only is it having an impact the police
scale and we predict that it's having an
impact on the final yields of these
plants but when you take the mechanistic
understanding of what's happening with
these systems and you plug it into a
model and you ignore acclimation you're
actually probably okay in elevated Coq
right acclimation probably doesn't make
big difference nowadays
um and there's reasons for that
um that mechanistically makes sense but
once you get into elevated temperatures
and you ignore that acclimation response
um then your model is not going to match
up with what we're measuring the field
I want to point out this is very
specific to soybean soybean we see that
there's this decline in VC Max but no
change in jmax and as CO2 goes higher
and higher you're more likely to be
jmax limited and so losses in BC Max are
not a big deal right but not all species
are the same and so if you look at
certain grasses and shrubs and trees
well these models predict that you're
going to be limited by VC Max both under
current and future CO2 concentrations
and so ignoring BC Max in those models
in those systems you might actually be
grossly overestimating what's happening
and so keep in mind this is a very
agricultural soybean C3 Focus right now
um but uh there's a lot more that needs
to be done to understand what's going on
with these other systems
so I wanted to point out that it's not
just about yields right I mean
Illinois we live breathe and die we make
a joke we have both kinds of plants corn
and soybeans right and you know I mean
walking up the steps here today seeing
all these different shaped leaves are
like crazy
um but it's not just yield for me I mean
there's a lot of other facts of my
research that I find um in fact I'm not
even a huge fan of corn and soybean to
be honest with you don't tell Illinois
that
um but um it's also quality nutritional
quality is extremely important and I
know most important soybeans don't go to
feed humans but nevertheless nutritional
quality is important and so a few years
ago there was a study that was published
I'm not part of this but it was showing
you that in elevated CO2 for a number of
different types of crops you're seeing a
decline in the nutritional quality
um of of the final product and so we're
curious whether or not our experiment
showed similar types of responses
and so this is just showing you a number
of different elements
um of the yield this is work that um I
did in collaboration with Ivan Baxter at
Danforth
um this is our previous reports from
other studies showing consistent
declines in a lot of the various
different nutritional components of of
the yield and just for two of the years
of our studies we see that you know
either we see no difference or we see
declines in elevated CO2 and so we're
seeing either no change in nutritional
quality or we're seeing a decline we're
not seeing any improvements in equality
um in in these soybean plants grown in
elevated CO2 when you look at the
temperature effects we actually see that
while yields tend to go down the quality
of that yield tends to go up and so
where there are changes here with the
exception of phosphorus where there are
changes they're almost always to a
higher nutritional quality and so while
there's a lot of work showing that
elevated CO2 drives nutritional quality
down elevated temperature tends to
improve the nutritional quality and when
you grow them together which isn't shown
here they tend to offset each other and
so you end up with no real big change in
yield and you end up or a potential
decline in year
end up with no real big change in
nutritional quality
um we also looked at um oil and protein
content and we actually this was just
done at different layers of the canopy
but we saw some mixed results here and
so the oil
um uh percentage oil of the soybean went
up in elevated temperature but didn't
change in elevated CO2 and the amount of
protein as consequence went down in one
year we saw generally similar results
but a lot more variation in 2015 and
we're not entirely sure why I mean so
more more research is in the process
were just waiting for Ivan to do the
analysis on the um on the yields
so
everything I've talked about right now
is focusing on elevated CO2 and global
warming
and I've been talking about global
warming in the context of just mean
increases in global temperature
fact is
um
and that's what this is showing here
this is probability plots of temperature
the average is here and we're predicting
the average is Shifting to here and
we're assimilating three degrees Celsius
in the experiments that I've been
preventing this part
but we can also end up with an increase
in variance in temperature and that's
what's shown in this middle figure here
where the actual mean temperature
doesn't change but you're seeing that
you're you're pushing down on the on the
probability plot and so the the low and
the high extremes balloon upward a
little bit and so that's an increase in
variance if you actually add these
together we end up with an increase in
mean temperature as well as an increased
probability of high temperature extreme
events
and if you actually look at data that's
been collected over the last few decades
this was from the 1950 to 60. as we move
down to the most recent decade from 2011
to 2020 you'll see that we're seeing a
shift to the right global warming but
we're also seeing the ballooning on the
high temperature extremes and so we're
seeing both an increase in mean
temperatures as well as an increase in
variance and that means a warmer planet
with higher much higher probability of
extremes
and so one of the things that I did when
I first set up this tea face experiment
in 2008 was I set up the Prototype I
turned it on and I was excited um so I
went to lunch
and I came back and realized that I got
a decimal placed wrong and instead of
hitting about a five or three degree
temperature increase it was up to 18
degrees Celsius and I killed the
Prototype plants they all died
um and and I realized now that well we
could actually get up to 18 degree
temperature increases and that's not
advisable
um but after we got done with this first
phase of experiment I thought to myself
like let's simulate heat waves because
they're becoming more common and they're
probably going to continue to become
even more common in the future
and so we designed this experiment where
um we wanted to impose a heatwave
but we wanted to make sure that the heat
wave we imposed is not actually just
kind of like raising the temperature to
an Optimum or rather raising the
temperature to an extreme
and so what I did was I looked at the
long-term means and I came up with this
temperature diurnal temperature response
which would be the blue line of what
would happen on an average day in
Illinois on this day right and so that's
the Blue Line This Is Our Baseline right
and then we wanted to say okay how much
of a temperature increase do we want to
give I'm like well let's do six degrees
I did an analysis and showed that 60
degree temperature heat wave in the
summer is statistically probable enough
that we should you know that there was a
threshold it was a threshold that seemed
plausible at the time although I would
probably argue to be higher now it was
10 years ago eight years ago
and so that would be the red line and
this red line
um or I'm sorry that would be six
degrees temperature increase and so the
goal was to increase the temperature
to six degrees above whatever is
happening on that day
but always to get above
the mean temperature for that day and I
and I just made a mistake and I realized
that this black line is your 30-year
move right and so what we're shooting
for is our treatment actually wants to
be this blue line or higher so we want
to impose a heat wave that six degrees
Celsius warmer than the average
temperature at least all right and so
what I mean by that is on this
particular day you'll see this black
these black dots this represents the
actual canopy temperature measure in our
reference plot
we got down to 12 degrees Celsius on
this day so if we increase this
temperature by six degrees we're going
to be at 18 degrees which is here which
is kind of Ideal right that's not really
a temperature stress and so in this
situation we wanted to increase the
temperature at least to this blue line
and there's a lot of variation here but
that's what we did on average
and then as the day Progressive
progresses all these lines are shifting
because you know diurnal fluctuations in
temperature and we did not want to go
above this red line because that's the
death zone we did not want to kill these
planets we wanted to stress them but we
didn't want to kill them and so we never
we tried to never go above this
you might be asking yourself why this
variation I like this state because it
shows you the really cool temperatures a
lot of wind where we lost the ability to
control the temperature control all of a
sudden the temperature started to
increase because the front finished
passing through
now we see that the variation in the in
the in the actual measure are our
control actually tightens up and then we
have this Knight where it was really
still and we see the upper threshold of
how good we can control the temperature
and so this is showing you the extremes
of what we can get
higher temperatures of the canopy with a
lot of variation higher temperatures of
the canopy with actually practically no
variation and this is all just driven by
how fast the wind is moving that heat
away from the plant canopy and so we
have these three different
um plots four different plots control
never got a heat wave plots one got a
heat wave early in in vegetative
development and plots two and three got
heat waves in reproductive develop early
and late reproductive development each
plot only got one artificially imposed
heat wave
and we replicated that three times
and so this is kind of what it looks
like the red and the black line and we
matched
um uh the erga the infrared radiometers
and then we turned on the Heat Wave and
then we're looking at these red lines
the heated the black line is the
non-heated and um what we see
um is that this is just there's a lot
going on here but this is showing you uh
measurements at the leaf level for
temperature photosynthesis the mild
conductance and Cloud efficiency of
photosystem Two And this is for three
heat waves in in uh the first year of
the experiment
um and then two heat waves uh vegetative
and reproductive in the second phase or
second year of this experiment and I
want to point out that um there's a lot
in this graph But ultimately what we're
seeing is that there is definitely
physiological responses of these plants
to the heat waves that we impose
right and that's the Divergence of the
red and the black lines
sometimes it's greater than others in
almost every situation where we saw a
response it was going to either be
warmer temperature or lower
photosynthesis lower smile conductance
um and generally speaking not a whole
lot with final efficiency post system
too except maybe on one or two days
but because no matter when we gave these
heat waves
we were imposing a strong physiological
response to the plants
when you actually look at the impact of
these heat waves on Final yield however
all of our results suggest that a heat
wave during vegetative growth of soybean
has no impact on the final yield so the
plants are able to recover
but any heat wave that we impose on
these plants during reproductive growth
whether it was early or late and
reproductive growth we ended up seeing a
decline in your final yields and so all
the all the treatment saw physiological
responses but only in the reproductive
phase of this experiment do they
actually translate to decreases in in
final yield
and then of course we want to take a
next step to see whether or not CO2 has
an impact on this and these are just
another two experiments that we did
um in 2015 and 2016. um here we did a
nine degree temperature increase and
again this was a postdoc that made a
mistake didn't kill the plants but boy
did she really uh eat them up and and
which was great and what we see is that
these really high temperature treatments
it seems that the elevated CO2 plants
um uh heating plus elevated CO2 plants
saw a greater decline in yield
um than when we only heated by about
five degrees and so it suggests that
another layer of complexity is not only
does it matter when the heat wave is
going to hit but the intensity of the
heat wave is also a major factor but it
seems like the elevated CO2 with the
heating Heat Wave
um it the elevates CO2 doesn't seem to
provide us a great deal of protection
um against against the Heat waves and so
from our analysis at least with soybean
it would suggest that as these heat
waves become more and more common the
rise in CO2 despite the increase in
productivity associated with elevated
CO2 may not necessarily provide any sort
of protection against um the heat waves
that were likely to continue
experiencing
and so this also shows up um at least in
2015 where we saw the huge impact we saw
final yield levels are are um are down
regardless of whether or not CO2 is
present but in the in the lower year you
know we actually saw this is the first
year we saw this really significant
um increase in this one scenario in
yield and so there is this threshold
idea right so how much of a heat wave is
really going to be enough
um for that Tipping Point to be reached
um that's something that we would like
to get at but um uh you know and
hopefully we will at some point this is
an evolving experimental facility
but before we get there one of the
things that really came up that were of
interest is uh recently there was a
project funded not recycled it's been
like 10 years now um kovid throws time
off I don't know
um but it's it's uh it's this project to
try to improve photosynthetic efficiency
of crops and it's um it's the realizing
um increased photos efficiency project
at the University of Illinois and the
goal is to try to overcome the fact that
for a lot of our crops particularly the
C3 crops we're seeing yield increases
per decade are starting to decline in
fact they have been in Decline for some
time and so new techniques new methods
and New Opportunities need to be sought
in order to realize increases in
yield
um that extend beyond what traditional
breeding has been able to do
and so
some of the work these genetic
modifications that I'm going to be
talking about are not work that I do I'm
a physiologist mostly environmental
physiologists but I work with people who
do a lot of genetic modifications of
plants and so Steve Long's group in
collaboration with Christine Reigns at
the University of Essex
they did a modeling analysis to try to
optimize the Calvin cycle enzymes and
see are they optimal for plants growing
in today's atmosphere and and how do
they need to be optimized for the future
environmental conditions and in this
optimization strategy which I'm not
going to get too much into depth with
um they identified that in order to
optimize cellulose bisphosphatase one of
the one of the nine Calvin cycle enzymes
for
future conditions you should actually
have almost an order of magnitude higher
concentrations of scpas and so there's
right now it's sub it's sub-optimal and
the theory that Steve came up with when
he did this was that it's sub-optimal
because plants evolved in lower CO2 than
they're experiencing right now and CO2
concentrations have gone up quite
substantially in a short period of time
and the plants haven't been able to keep
up
another strategy
um that is used to try to improve
photosynthetic efficiency is a photo
respiratory bypass and so C3 plants will
actually assimilate oxygen in oxygenase
activity of rubisco
and drives this photo respiratory
pathway that requires quite a bit of
energy loss of carbon dioxide and
shuttling of carbon amongst three
different organelles and so the idea is
to try to come up with a bypass where
this
glycolate that's produced from this act
of donation can just be processed here
in the in the chloroplast with less
energy and the CO2 is still going to be
released but at least it's being
released around rubisco where
photosynthesis you know the primary
entry point of carbon into the plant
and so these are two strategies that we
considered might actually be pretty good
with regards to
um
resilience to high temperature
and so um that's because this is a graph
from earlier showing that high
temperature jmax tends to go down right
and sbps is one of the enzymes that's
responsible for regenerating our ubp
and so in theory if we see an elevated
temperature that this black line here
goes down to this dashed line because of
photosynthetic acclimation can we just
try to manipulate this this line This
dashed line to come back up here and we
thought sppa seems like it might be a
strategy to do that and so these are the
sppa silver expressing lines of tobacco
that Christine Reigns grew are developed
at the University of Essex and it's
showing you under just control control
conditions in a greenhouse or growth
chamber your wild type plants are
smaller than your spph silver expressing
lines
um and so um and she also showed that uh
by measuring CO2 photosynthetic CO2
response curves these sppa silver
expressors are actually looking at
higher
um uh jmax values all right and so it
seems like this would work well in high
temperature and so we actually did grow
um we actually got sppa silver
expression in in in soybean all right we
actually work a lot with tobacco in
Illinois but obviously I not a huge fan
of corn soybean I'm even less of a fan
of tobacco but it's a great model crop
species and so it's fun to work with but
that's it
um and so we got this in the soybean
because that's really what we're
interested in and this was um in
collaboration with Steve Wong and so we
grew both of these in the um temperature
experiment on soy face
and what we basically saw was
um that we actually saw slight deep
increases in the um EPA silver
expressures both in terms of VC Max and
in jmax
and so that was a bit surprising seeing
this VC Max response but the jmax
response was something that we predicted
and for three different years of
experimentation
um we saw that and we also saw that
photosynthetic rates in the wild type
versus the sppas overexpressors and this
is for all treatments
um has actually gone up
um uh in in most of the uh so this is
morning midday and afternoon for three
different years mostly in the midday and
the afternoon is where we saw the
greatest increases in temperature and it
turns out that the higher the light
and the higher the temperature the
greater the stimulation in
photosynthesis as a result of the sppa's
overexpressing lines
but the big question we had was what
does this mean for the temperature
treatments or the CO2 treatments and so
what we saw actually surprised us which
is that for the control
elevated temperature and elevated CO2
treatments there were no differences
that we can observe in final yield
between the control and as the wild type
and the svk silver espresso and this was
for all three years with the exception
of you know this one control anomaly
that we had in the third year
what we also saw this was I showed you
this earlier I said ignore the gray bar
now don't ignore three virus
um what we're seeing is that the sppa
sober expressors in all three years
um actually had higher yield in the CO2
plus temperature treatment and so it
seems as if sppa silver expression
doesn't lead to higher yields in high
CO2 and high temperature but it does
protect the plants the final yield
against the detrimental impacts of
higher temperature
and we're not entirely sure why except
that this was observed three years in a
row and so
um there's a lot of questions but it
suggests an opportunity for adaptation
high temperatures
and just briefly I'm going to just
present some of the work on the photorey
bypass and so this is again work that
I've done with the collaborator this
time it's done org and a postdoc in his
group Amanda Kavanaugh where they
developed these not only do they have to
come up with this um pathway in the
chloroplast to metabolize the possible
glycolate but they also had to actually
cut out a transporter that competes with
that fossil glycolate being transported
out of the chloroplasts they actually
had to stop the export of the glycolate
from the chloroplasts and so this is
this alone doesn't do anything you have
to actually knock out one transporter
and so we got our hands on these and we
grew them out at um this time it's
tobacco right not funded by Philip
Morris I promise
um and we did uh in one year we imposed
two different life cycles tobacco has a
pretty short life cycle in Illinois and
so we grew two different cohorts of
plants an early season experiment that
was harvested and analyzed and then
later season experiment and so there are
two different heat waves that we imposed
um and um on two different lines uh two
different separate experiments and we're
shooting for a five degree temperature
increase in these um or sorry it's not a
heat wave it's we grew them the whole
life cycle
um but so this this is the entire
lifespan for tobacco early season and
the entire lifespan of tobacco for the
late season you know and what we saw is
that the SP or sorry the polar
respiratory bypass had higher
photosynthetic rates their thermal
Optimum seem to shift to higher
temperatures
um and um and and that occurred despite
not a whole lot of change in your your
VC Max or your or your jmax
um and so it suggested that there's not
a whole lot of photosynthetic
affirmation going on here but this
photorespiratory bypass is yielding
slightly higher photosynthetic rates
um what we did see however is that um
the wild type plants we saw a decrease
in above ground drill Mass above ground
dry biomass in both the wild type and
the photorespiratory bypass lines and um
and we saw this
um we're both experiments but if you
actually look at the wild type
um
biomass decreased
by about
um 35 in elevated temperature
whereas the photorespiratory bypass also
decreased in high temperature but they
only decreased by about 15 to 18 percent
and so again it's one of these ideas
where implementing this photorespiratory
bypass can increase potentially
increased biomass we don't know about
yields because this is tobacco right the
seeds are ridiculously small and no one
wants to harvest those anyway this is
just biomass but what we see is that
this photorespiratory bypass does not
result in higher
ability to adapt to height it doesn't
increase your photosynthesis or your
your biomass and elevated temperature
but it does protect against some of that
loss in higher temperature
it's going to finish with something we
just started and so for
at least two or three of you based on my
experiences in talking about this work
are probably sitting there thinking to
yourselves throughout this entire
seminar You Know Carl
when you're increasing the canopy
temperature aren't you also messing with
the vapor pressure deficit all right and
answer is absolutely
and so as we use these infrared heaters
and we shine them on the plants right
we're increasing the canopy temperature
but we're also changing the leaf to air
vapor pressure deficit
BPD is a really important parameter for
how plants grow right it dictates how
much water is being lost to the plant
and has this impact on the stomata
and so what we've done what my lab's
done I I've been working the last year
and a half to build the system which we
just built and it's been out in the
field
um this was actually from last year this
is just prototype
um where what we're doing is we're
increasing the canopy temperature as
I've been talking about through this
whole seminar now but in addition to
that I built a misting system that
atomizes water vapor and will actually
inject water vapor into the air to
increase the atmospheric humidity at the
same time that we're increasing the
canopy temperature and so this is just
showing you some of the control this is
our control this is the mean and the um
you know this box plots of BPD and then
the elevated temperature treatments you
could see that this VPD is Shifting to
much higher values and that's because
we're artificially increasing canopy
temperature
this first year we over applied the
relative the water vapor but
nevertheless we're seeing really strong
this is high temperature plus the
additional additional atmospheric
humidity and we're seeing that our VPD
is much lower than the people so we
actually have three different VPD
treatments here and two different
temperature treatments our goal this
year which I we should get the data
pretty soon was to try to match this and
this as closely as we possibly can and I
don't know if we've done it but it looks
promising so far and what this is going
to do is it's I've postdoc Nick DeLucia
who some of you might know his dad Evan
Lucia
um he's been out there making a ton of
measurements on these plants throughout
their entire life cycle
um to try to understand what are the
physiological implications particularly
related to photosynthesis of the
elevated temperature versus the elevated
temperature plus the higher VP
treatments relative to the control and
for those of you who do any sort of
ecosystem modeling that's one of the
hardest things to get at right now is
understanding the temperature versus VPD
effect because they tend to change
together almost universally so
all right that was a lot I hope I didn't
go over
um and uh maybe went under I guess I
talked last time I gave this so I went
over
um before I finish I do have to
acknowledge the fact that everything
I've done on on this is a collaboration
between me and postdoctoral and grad
researchers and the grad students in my
lab as well as collaborations with a lot
of my colleagues including Donald Steve
long and the postdocs and graduate
students in their lab so this is like
collaboration with the capital c and I
need to acknowledge them and all the
people that have contributed to various
different aspects of This research so
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions you may have and I appreciate
your attention thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu